这从你的这个角度确实不好搞，
我要是你的话，
我可能就吹枕边风，
我说今天哎哟，
哪个老太太给人家打赏主播打赏了几十万喽，
哪个老太太又拿他的棺材本儿，
外面那个老头骗他，
给他棺材本儿都骗走了，
哪个老太太在网上哎呀跟靳东谈恋爱哟，
真有老太太以为靳东要追她，
完了之后跟人家谈恋爱，
给人家搞了几百万的都有，
哪个老太太就在网上被人家骗，
买什么股票喽，
买什么预床喽，
买什么保健品喽，
又骗了几十万喽，
我天天给他说这个，
我让我老公自己意识到，
如果她不主动去把这个钱的事儿琢磨明白的话，
这钱就打水漂了，
我自己不去干这事儿，
我不去充当这个坏人，
我想把家里的事儿跟您说一下，
我结婚已经19年了，
我们结婚了之后呢，
我爸妈当时开了一个厂子，
然后我妈妈就说这个厂子呢，
给我和我弟弟一人一半儿，
但是我当时已经考上了公务员，
我有了工作，
对于我们家这个厂子呢，
就让我公公打理着，
等于说我公公没有投资，
就跟我妈妈，
跟我爸爸他们一起做了生意，
这些年呢，
因为我上着班儿，
我也弄孩子，
我老公也上着班儿，
所以这厂子呢，
一直都是我公公我妈妈他们在经营。
在八年前，
我妈。
去世了，
去世了之后呢，
这场子就是我公公和我弟弟一起经营，
这场子是所有的分红，
最开始是我妈妈跟我公公，
后来呢就没有妈妈，
之后是我公公和弟弟他们在分红，
家里的钱我也没问过，
孩子上小学的时候不在我们县里上了，
我去了石家庄，
河北那边有个省会，
陪着孩子去上学，
然后这些年呢，
我公公和我婆婆几乎没有管过孩子的事儿，
最开始我们到那是租房，
后来买了房子，
孩子学费是在上初中的时候，
去了一个私立学校，
孩子他爷爷他每年给孩子交的学费，
然后在省会城市买了个房子，
就这些，
然后我公公呢，
前年的时候去世了，
去世了之后家里所有的钱我也没问过，
后来我跟孩子爸爸，
我说你问问我妈妈看看，
公公当时有了多少钱，
因为我们家以前所有的钱，
所我婆婆她也有工作，
她的银行卡，
她所有的钱都是我工人在管，
我婆婆就没有去过银行，
我说你问问大概的数，
她说没有了，
爸爸怎么问这个事儿，
他也不问，
我说你看这个钱呢，
没有我了，
爸爸她名下的所有的钱，
我也不知道银行怎么处理，
我问不合适，
你去问问妈妈，
然后他就说，
他说我没法问，
又说了一次，
她说她问了一次，
他妈妈不告诉他，
他说你去问吧，
我就问了我婆婆一次，
因为孩子今年大。
学的时候考上了一个澳门的大学，
学费特别高，
一年学费加上住宿费要20多万，
我婆婆跟我说，
公公走的时候就留了10万块钱两张存单，
但是她说还不到期，
我说那就等等吧，
后来孩子开学的时候，
他说孩子到期，
他记错日期了，
我也没再问他，
孩子开学以后就没几天，
孩子爸爸把那个存单拿回家了，
我一看是公公的名字，
因为当时我公住院的时候跟我老公说，
他说给我婆婆存了大额的存单，
但是没有收回多少钱，
我说那应该不是这个存单，
因为当时说的是我婆婆的名字，
然后我就问我婆婆，
他说我没说，
就是十万块钱，
有钱就是没说，
哎，
因为这个事儿，
我老公和我跟我婆婆之间闹的特别不愉快，
直到现在，
他现在70多岁了，
就是整天闹事儿，
折腾这两个孩子，
我作为儿媳妇，
我没说过别的，
就是孩子上学的学费也好，
还有什么乱七八糟的其他费用也好，
他什都没管我们，
但是我对这老粮特别孝顺，
对他们特别好，
家里所有的东西，
他们衣服学什么的都是我给他妈妈，
我就想知道你给你看，
因为这个厂子当时是我妈妈给我和我弟弟的，
只不过是让我公公代为管理，
但是之间没有什么正式的合同呀，
协议什么的，
那么现在就是厂里分红这些钱，
我公公婆婆他们的公。
这我觉得无所谓，
就厂里分红这一年，
这有将近20年的分红，
我不知道时候有多少钱，
但是起码得有大几百万，
您觉得这个事儿我怎么处理好？
你老公是独生子吗？
对，
她还有个妹妹，
妹妹成家了吗？
是家了。
客观的分析，
你觉得你的婆婆对儿子和女儿感情是什么样的？
我感觉像您说的那个NPD人格，
那就是折腾孩子，
没有公公之后我说我们搬在那，
她说楼上不让装修，
只能装修他楼下，
但是那房子老啊，
楼上没法住，
然后我公公陪他在那边住了一年，
我老公一出门他就得给孩子姑姑打电话，
给我小姑子打电话，
就家里几分钟没有人都不行，
他不停的折腾你，
然后说做的饭什么不好吃，
这不行那不行的，
反正就特别事儿多是这样的啊，
你婆婆呢，
现在70多岁了，
她再婚的可能性呢，
也是比较小，
不太可能再婚了是吧？
对，
然后呢，
你的老公呢，
他是唯一的儿子，
有一个小姑子，
其实这事儿的话，
从你的这个角度来看，
你觉得当初是你娘家的家业，
你的公公只不过是去帮忙代管，
但是公公他能够代管出来家业更大，
能够代管出来挣更多的钱，
能够代管出来有几百万的存款，
这事儿也不是一般人能干成的，
因为让你去代管的话，
你未必能像你公公这样。
可能代管出来这样的结果，
所以这事儿虽然说从源头上来看是娘家的产业，
但是公公在这个过程当中，
他肯定也是付出了劳动，
付出了心力，
他有能力的，
他才能代款出这个结果。
再加上公公死了之后，
你娘家那边产业也没说要分多少产业给公公，
没说这事儿就相当于公公死了之后，
这些产业又回到了你的弟弟手上，
不是他现在没有了我公公之后，
这厂子就是我跟我弟弟在管理了，
就是你和你弟弟在管理了，
对，
但是之前的那些这些年分红的所有的钱，
现在应该是在我婆婆手里，
但是应该是在我公公名下，
是这样，
一般情况下举个例子说，
你公公名下有300万的存款，
这300万的存款如果想要变更到你婆婆名下呢，
他很复杂，
他是需要去世的人的，
所有的继承人都得要签字才行，
就包括你的老公，
包括你的小姑子都得去签字，
他才能办这个变更的手续，
否则的话，
这300万就是死在你公公的账上取不出来的，
其实我觉得这事儿呢，
也有一定的好处，
就放在公公的名下，
以后等婆婆也去世了之后，
该怎么分怎么分，
如果她知道存折的密码，
银行的密码呢，
他是可以取得出来的，
比如说她是一张卡，
她要知道这张卡的取款密码，
他从。
M机上是可以取出来的，
比如说他要是不告诉银行的人说我老公死了，
我只是单纯的拿着银行的存折去，
拿着老公的身份证去，
拿着我的身份证去，
是有可能也能取得出来钱的，
这是一个风险吧，
我感觉你这事儿呢，
你出面呢就不合适，
只有当你老公有一天琢磨过味儿来了，
他觉得这个钱如果说不分好，
不解决出来的话，
可能会以后影响他跟他妹妹之间的关系啊，
以后有可能说妈妈得了什么，
脑子不太清醒了，
容易被别人骗走啊，
容易被诈骗呀，
被人家卖保健品的，
卖各种神仙药的骗走啊，
只有那种出现紧急的，
害怕这个钱被别人骗走，
或者是害怕将来跟妹妹产生矛盾，
你老公他主张要去把这个钱分清楚的时候，
这事儿才好办，
你去办这个事儿确实不合适，
对，
因为我老公当时我们俩也跟他说，
就是在他手里没事儿，
但是你让我们知道个数，
因为毕竟他这个年龄了，
我一直就是说他拿着没问题，
但是让我们知道个数，
他从来不说，
他就是不说，
我纠结的点就是他两个除了工资以外，
其实家里大部分的钱是经营的那个分红，
那我问你啊，
当时公公给你们买了套学区房，
是多少钱呀，
100多万，
公公管你们家那个。
企业总共管了多少年呀？
将近20年吧，
其实这事儿你问你弟弟不就能问出来吗？
你弟弟是最清楚公公到底该有多少钱的呀，
我现在手里我有从20年到现在就是四年多的账，
这几年分了将近是300万吧，
每年就是几十万，
但之前挣的更多，
之前的账我和我弟弟手里都没有这个账之前是我妈妈和我公公那个，
这个账现在找不着了，
这事儿从你的这个角度确实不好搞，
我要是你的话，
我可能就吹枕边风，
我说今天哎呦，
哪个老太太给人家打赏主播打赏了几十万哦，
哪个老太太又拿他的棺材本儿，
外面那个老头骗他，
给他棺材本都骗走了哦，
哪个老太太在网上哎呀，
跟靳东谈恋爱哟，
真有老太太以为靳东要追她，
完了之后跟人家谈恋爱，
给人家搞了几百万的都有哪个老太太就在网上被人家骗，
买什么股票喽，
买什么预床喽，
买什么保健品喽，
又骗了几十万喽，
我天天给他说这个，
我让我老公自己意识到，
如果她不主动去把这个钱的事儿琢磨明白的话，
这钱就打水漂了，
我自己不去干这事儿，
我不去充当这个坏人，
但是呢，
是个挺自私的人，
我小姑子和我老公俩人都是整天也是筋疲力尽的，
我小姑子每天中午回家给他做饭，
但是。
他从来都不满意，
我们家除了我以外，
每天都是饱受他的折磨，
但这个事儿呢，
除了我刚刚说的这种情理上想办法之外，
其实在法律上是可以操作的，
但这事儿呢，
不能你来操作，
这事儿在法律上要是操作的话，
那就只能说提起一个诉讼，
要分割遗产，
分割父亲的遗产，
这个诉讼是给谁提起，
包括你的小姑子和你的老公，
他俩都有资格提，
他俩甚至可以一起提都行。
其实我感觉这事儿的话，
如果你老公和小姑子两个人对吧，
感情挺好的话，
可以打一个双簧，
哎，
我作为小姑子的话，
我就是说我要那个什么，
我不能让爸爸的财产都给我哥哥和嫂子了，
那我也得分一杯羹，
我就去提一个，
那前提条件是你们愿不愿意分给人家小姑子啊，
我姑公和我婆婆的工资，
我没有问过他们，
我也不管这一部分，
我只是说我们家这个厂子的分红这一部分钱，
因为这一部分钱呢，
最开始说的很明白，
是我妈妈给我和我弟弟的其他钱，
我不想他们分割，
怎么分割对我来说我觉得无所谓，
那我觉得你这个想法是不对的，
因为这个分红他不是白来的，
他是要公公付出时间、
精力、
命才能赚出来的分红，
你不能说这分红就得归你或者怎么样，
这个想法是不对的，
你要是打这个想法的话，
那你们家肯定得散，
我今天就把你这个想法打散了，
你这个家才能合。
公公不是说这分红完全是基于你们家的赐予，
基于你们家的恩赐得到的这个分红，
公公是在这里拼了命的，
付出了时间、
精力、
钱和命才得到的这个分红，
你没有白纸黑字的写清楚这个分红该怎么分，
那今天就是一笔糊涂账，
这笔糊涂账里面就是公公的命搭在里头了，
人家作为儿女也好，
作为妻子也好，
他就是能分这个红，
就是说其实这个钱并不能说，
那肯定不能都归你，
都归你的话就不公平，
人家又不是说你的奴力，
你安排去给你们家打工，
他就管口饭吃就行了。
公公他是一个活人，
他付出了时间、
精力、
劳动和命，
他就该挣这个钱，
如果说他只是一个打工的，
他挣不了那么多钱，
换句话说，
如果他是只是一个打工的，
他没有这个能力在的话，
这也拿不到那么多分红呀，
是不是他肯定是有能力在的呀，
是啊，
你得这么想问题啊，
你知道这属于这个事儿，
因为钱生起来气了，
因为孩子上大学什么的，
最开始之前学费，
我公公都是给孩子拿学费的，
因为家里的这些钱呢，
我跟孩子爸爸就挣我工资，
但是今年上学的时候，
我婆婆就跟我老公说，
就说孩子学学费不够，
你去想办法出去借钱吧，
骗我们说公公只留下了10万块钱，
后来我们才知道不是这么回事儿，
所以才生起来这个气，
反正我从情理上跟你讲了，
怎么处理这个事儿，
从法律上我。
跟你讲了，
如果你要处理这个事儿的话，
你将来面临的是什么呢？
公公名下的财产叫夫妻共同财产，
老太太是可以分一半走的，
剩下的才叫遗产，
剩下的遗产他是公公的法定继承人来继承。
公公的法定继承人有哪些呢？
就是他的配偶、
子女、
父母都有继承的资格，
是这么个算账的方法，
行，
我建议你不要处理这个事儿，
其实最好的方法就是天天给你老公吹枕边风，
又哪个老太太又被骗了多少钱？
又哪个老太太老糊涂了，
把自己钱给了谁谁谁，
又哪个老太太在网上又跟谁谁谁网恋了，
又被人家骗了多少钱？
嗯，
好，
就这样啊，
我跟姐妹们说啊，
我说可能今天你听到龙菲姐讲这个的话，
你心里会有一点哎呀，
不得劲儿，
但是你从长远来看，
如果我们打消了这个念头，
打消了时候，
公公名下的钱都应该是我娘家的分红，
那都应该给我，
你打消了这个念头，
你以后才有好日子过，
如果这个念头不打消的话，
你心里老觉得亏是吧？
但是某种程度上，
你看你这些年你得到了跟孩子相伴的快乐，
得到了孩子健健康康跟妈妈一起成长的幸福，
同时的话，
公公也买了一套学区房，
100多万，
而且公公也出过一些学费的，
这些东西是无价的，
包括陪孩子成长这些东西是无价的是吧？
没法用钱来衡量的，
从这个角度来看的话，
还是感恩人家公公，
感恩人家公公挺身而出，
在孩子最需要妈。
怕的时候人家公公去顶了你这个差事，
去娘家人去干这个工作了，
是吧？
所以说以后呢，
大家从这个故事当中会汲取什么经验呢？
就算是亲人，
就算是亲家，
就算是血缘关系一起要是做买卖做生意的话，
咱应该白纸黑字落下来，
记得点赞关注哦。